Allez, les Bleus!
Frankreich steht im Halbfinale der Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft.
Das Team von Trainer Didier Deschamps setzte
sich im ersten Viertelfinalspiel der WM in
Russland mit 2:0 gegen Uruguay durch.
Von den Pariser Champs-Elysees bis nach Nischni
Nowgorod jubelten die Fans der Equipe Tricolore.
Ein Kopfballtreffer durch Raphael Varane brachte
Frankreich in der 40. Minute in Führung.
Antoine Griezmann erhöhte nach einem saftigen
Patzer von Torwart Fernando Muslera in der
zweiten Halbzeit zum 2:0.
"Ich bin super happy.
Wir sind im Halbfinale, das hat es seit 2006
nicht mehr gegeben.
Jetzt werden wir die ganze Nacht durchfeiern.
Und wir bleiben in Russland bis zum Finale
und werden siegen."
Einige uruguayische Fans in Nischni Nowgorod
waren am Freitag in Tränen aufgelöst.
Andere trugen es mit Fassung.
"Was soll ich sagen?
ich bin Russin, aber für Uruguay.
Und jetzt haben wir verloren, es ist so traurig."
"Ohne Cavani ist alles ziemlich kompliziert.
Aber wir haben es wenigstens versucht."
Top-Stürmer Edinson Cavani, einer der Schlüsselspieler
Uruguays war wegen einer Wadenverletzung ausgefallen.